اعرب المنسق الاممي الخاص لعمليه السلام
في الشرق الاوسط
عن قلقه البالغ ازاء تاثير الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه العقابيه على الوضع المالي
للسلطه الفلسطينيه
واكد وينسلاند خلال جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس
الامن الدولي على ضروره محاسبه مرتكبي
اعمال العنف في الضفه الغربيه وتقديمه الى
العداله وعبر عن قلقه من تاثير اجراءات
اسرائيل العقديه على الوضع المالي للسلطه
الفلسطينيه
لدى الامم المتحده ان هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لا تعترف بحقوق الفلسطينيين
في اي مكان
وتعلنوا حقا لمستوطنيها في كل مكان واضاف
ان اسرائيل لا ترى ان العالم لا يستطيع ان
يحاسبها على افعلها الاحاديه غير
القانونيه ومع ذلك
ستسمحوا لنفسها بمعاقبه الفلسطينيين على
اللجوء الى اليات شرعيه
معنى من امام مجلس الامن في نيويورك
مراسله الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد طلعنا على
مجريات الجلسه وابرز التصريحات حتى الان
وسيله هذه هي الجلسه ربع السنويه المتعلقه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه والشرق الاوسط اجمالا
هناك
متحدثا في هذه الجلسه يمثلون الدول اغلبها
من خارج مجلس الامن حتى الان لازال
الاعضاء المجلس الامن يتحدثون في هذه
الجلسه سمعنا في بدايهتها من فوينس لاند
همم منسق عمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
وكان واضح ان تبنيه همم لغه همم حتى اقل
بكثير من من تلك اللغه التي يستخدمه
الامين العام للامم المتحده
ولا سينما همم في الجزئيه المتعلقه
بالاجراءات الاسرائيليه العقربيه ضد همم
الشعب الفلسطيني والسلطه الفلسطينيه
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني في فلسطين في
الاذاعه غرب عن القلق همم منها اييي فيما
الامين العام ادعى لانه لا ينبغي ان تكون
هناك اي اجراءات عقابيه جراء الرجل لجوء
فلسطين الى محكمه العدل الدوليه عبر قرار
من الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
والاسلاند اا اكد التزام الامم المتحده
بحال الدولتين والقدس عاصمه لكلتا
الدولتين وضمن حدود يونيو 77 عبر عن القلق
من تنامي حجه العنف واتهمما وصفهم
بالمتطرفين بمحاوله عرقله همم
السلام همم قال ان هناك منذ ثمانيه ديسمبر
حتى 14 الشهر الجاري هناك 14 قتيلا
فلسطينيا
وسبعه عشر جريحا بينهم اطفال ونساء وان
هناك 68 هجوما همم نفذه همم نفذها
مستوطنون اسرائيليون دعى الى وقت هذه
الاعمال اكد ايضا الاعراب عن القلق من
الاجراءات العقابيه في من يتعلق بالجانب
المالي للسلطه الفلسطينيه
المندوب الامريكيه ايضا كان لافتا تاكيدها
تاكيد التزامها التزام بلدها بحل الدولتين
وايضا القلق من الاجراءات الاحاديه بما في
ذلك ما يتعلق بالوضع الراهن في الحرم
الشريف وكذلك بناء المستوطنات او التقنيين
بناء المستوطنات ايضا
ما وصفتها بالاعمال الارهابيه بتبعه هل هي
تكرر ذلك الموقف الصادر عن الاداره
الامريكيه لكن مندوب فلسطين وجه رساله
واضحه الى مجلس الامن عليه ان يتخذ همم
اجراءات وان يمارسك كافه نفوذه وتاتيره من
اجل تحقيق السلام وضمان قيام دوله
فلسطينيه قبل ان يفوت الاوان وسيله شكرا